super exciting announcement to make
today a few months ago I announced that
the david pakman show YouTube channel
which at the time had around 400,000
subscribers had been invited to
participate in a beta test of something
called YouTube membership what that
allowed was for our then 400,000
subscribers if they want to support the
work that we do for $4.99 a month
through YouTube by virtue of clicking
this button that says join which many of
you saw when watching our videos and
when you would click that button you
could join for $4.99 a month and this
was very cool and we've been trying it
out and we've been growing our support
on YouTube it's all fine well and good
we have now been invited by YouTube to a
sub beta test and when I say sub beta
it's not like some kind of you know
bondage type of thing or anything
related to beta males or anything like
that we've been invited to a smaller
beta group where we now have multiple
tiers at which you can support us on
YouTube starting at $1.99 so now when
you click the join button you get five
options and they each have names for
$1.99 a month you can be a soy boy okay
$1.99 a month
soy boy for $4.99 a month you are a beta
for $14.99 a month you become alpha for
$49.99 a month you are president of the
David Pakman show and lastly at the
$99.99 a month level for the real high
rollers you become me you become David
Pakman which is both scary and very very
exhilarating so you can read about the
levels and sign up on YouTube it's
really easy to do the join button should
now show up on all of our pages and all
of our video pages and our channel home
page now disclaimer okay this is really
important because every time we do
something like this I get a hundred
emails from people that are confused if
you're currently a member if you're
currently a patron you don't need to
change anything there's no reason to
change anything there's no reason to
cancel what you're doing now and move
over to
YouTube this is just a cool new thing we
have five hundred and sixty thousand
subscribers now on YouTube if we can get
just one percent to sign up at the
dollar ninety-nine a month level that is
a huge huge win but you don't need to
change anything and everything's fine
with membership and patreon one other
important note I've been advised by
YouTube that the join button is not
currently visible on iOS devices but we
are putting a link to the join page in
the video description for all new videos
so you can use that link on an iOS
device but also importantly if you use
that link on an iOS device you will only
see the cheapest tier of $1.99 a month
to see all of the tiers on an iOS device
you have to look at it on a computer
browser of some kind let's call this the
1% project if we can get 1% of our
YouTube audience to sign up for a
membership at a dollar ninety-nine a
month it would be huge but don't stress
if you remember if you're a patron no
need to change what you're doing what
you're doing is lovely and we love it